- If we talk about our
traditional architecture
here in Senegal, we cannot not talk about
earth architecture because
everything was built with earth,
and during the industrialisation,
the colonists made us think
that concrete was better,
that it was faster.
I really want to prove people
that earth architecture
can be as modern, as circular you know...
It could fix a lot of problems.
- What's really interesting
is the new technologies
that we have can really push that material
to a different place.
That becomes a really
interesting narrative
of an existing historical material
becoming a future material.
- I think it's the job
of every architect now
here in Senegal, all the young architects,
to promote this material.
- And it's contextual.
It's a material that's found
in a place, it's abundant.
That's why it was built with before.
I'm creating a contextual
materials library for Johannesburg
a materials archive of what's
happening in Johannesburg
within a circular design context.
The whole intention is then
to bring Johannesburg-based
designers into a space
to communicate about the
material makeup of Johannesburg,
and therefore, we start
to create this really, really,
really interesting archive
where people are become
a part of the movement,
they become emotionally
invested in these materials
because we're talking about
them, what do they mean to you?